elle a changé de visage lot de chevreuse
et au mois de septembre devenu la
lutetia la seule eau minérale naturelle
d'île de france
elle est aujourd'hui référencé dans
toutes les enseignes franciliennes en
2009 il a été fait un sondage auprès des
consommateurs franciliens vis-à-vis de
la marque chevreuse et du fait que il au
niveau l'identité les consommateurs ne
se retrouvait pas forcément notamment
vis-à-vis d'eux
voilà la localisation
chevreuse ou est ce que c'est la
livraison se fait dans un rayon de 150
kilomètres maximum l'eau puisée à plus
de 600 mètres de profondeur est entouré
à 90% de forêt à quelques pas de lusine
c'est nous qui a une faible composition
en minéraux auxquels s'adaptent
également à toute la famille notamment
nourrisson est on est on retrouve
d'ailleurs sur l'étiquette le logo
adapté à la console à l'alimentation des
noues
aussi nos pieds faibles en sodium donc
elle s'adapte aussi à des régimes
spécifiques
là on demandait
une faible consommation de sel c'est
vraiment
qui va s'adapter à tout la fête le
groupe au jeu et propriétaire de la
source située dans la vallée de
chevreuse depuis 2013
aujourd'hui la capacité de production
est de 28 mille bouteilles à l'heure
elle est disponible dans deux formats 1
litre et demi 50 centilitres pour
l'année 2020 t1 le groupe vise 80
millions de bouteilles produites sur le
site